Sonne recently announced that's you a
potty quiz game that's based on the play
link service then you platforms it links
your phone to your ps4 so I grab some
friends so you can check out how it
plays and hopefully witness some
embarrassing moments looks like we're
ready first things first this is a game
like no other here the only thing you
need to know is each other
okay time to start with the questions
these are real simple you just have to
tell me who the answer is come away from
a pottery weekend with a clay blob who's
it gonna be
looks like we've got our answer would
make a 3-foot tall sculpture of their
face I've always had plans for an
80-foot concrete one it makes sense to
construct a small clay prototype let's
see what everyone thinks you guys can
have an extra Joker for being so in sync
this next game is all about your inner
doodler so one of you is gonna take a
photo of someone posing and then you're
all gonna draw all over
[Music]
my face
[Music]
[Music]
all right Oh what do we got
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think we can all be proud of what
we've created let's get out of here okay
sorry to break it to you like this but
there's a huge lump of space dust
heading this way and the world's gonna
end this time tomorrow now time for
another picture question what would they
be doing as the world ends there's one
person that bed with one leg let's see
the results of this one
for everyone who read crosswords and
recreational guys the mixed result for
the Joker's their time to find out who's
the mimic in the room I'm going to show
you guys a photo of someone or something
and you have to photograph yourselves
imitating it mimic this picture right
let's have
[Laughter]
[Music]
now for the foot great minds think alike
huh what do you know
it missed now let's do another writing
challenge as before think what this
person would say here yeah quick yet
each is gone out let's
[Music]
[Music]
okay Wow
it's a two-way split all right everyone
eyes down
hold on to your chairs guys we've only
got time for one more but it's a real
beaut you're all gonna take selfies and
turn them into masterpieces don't take
them too close now or you'll have
nothing to work with
seeing something you like yeah well when
you're ready we can get drawing
[Music]
steal yourselves now you are about to
receive someone selfie check out the
picture and get thinking about what
you're gonna do we're about to start
[Music]
okay all right five seconds left at a
time can't wait to see them and that
makes you our winner doesn't matter a
dime that you need a minder to use a can
opener when you're such an amazing judge
of character
congratulations